[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC KOLEDA: Hello, and welcome
to "Google Apps
Unscripted." My name's
Eric Koleda.
DAN LAZIN: And I'm Dan Lazin.
ERIC KOLEDA: And we are from
the Google Apps Script
Developer Relations team here
with another edition of our
show, where we are unscripted.
And we basically just cover
recent news and events in the
Google Apps Script world, show
you some cool stuff you might
not have known about, and then
answer questions live from the
audience via Google Hangout.
So if you are watching us live
on YouTube, if you head over
to the googledevelopers
.google.com/live page, you can
see a link at the top that
says Join the Hangout.
Come on in, ask some
questions, and
we'll have a good time.
All right.
So we've got some news
to cover first,
before we get to questions.
One of the big things is just
yesterday me and Dan pushed
the giant red button to launch
some new documentation, or a
refresh of our documentation.
So you can find our
documentation, as always, on
developers.googl
e.com/apps-script, Apps Script.
And if you could take a look
here at the screen, you'll see
that there's a lot of changes
that have come through in this
recent documentation change.
So one of the big ones is our
homepage got completely
redesigned.
Dan here did a great job
of the design work.
And you can see that it's
much more inviting.
But separate from just being
a better-looking design, it
really helps people get to the
content they need faster,
right, Dan?
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
I think there actually will
probably be some people who
are watching us in the future
on this page right now,
because you scroll down to the
bottom of the page there,
you'll see one of the things
we brought in is recent
release notes and a playlist
of all of our "Apps Script
Google Developers Live" app.
So it's just like this one.
So it's possible that we are
inside this page right now,
sort of very meta, pointing
over at the release notes,
pointing out the new design.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So this is great.
DAN LAZIN: It's blowing
my mind.
ERIC KOLEDA: Getting the video
there, getting the release
notes, that really helps you get
some information upfront.
But I also really love these
buttons that jump right into
quickstarts and tutorials.
A lot of people come to our
documentation and they want to
just get started.
They don't want to spend a lot
of time reading a book.
They want to start coding
right away.
They want to do something
interesting.
And I feel like these four
little buttons you got here
really help direct users
in that direction.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
And I think we allow for a lot
of different ways for people
to get engaged with
Apps Script.
For one, as we talked about,
there's the videos
right on the page.
There's a sort of sense that
Apps Script is a continually
developing product, by the
frequently updated release
notes there.
We've got these quickstart
tutorials that Eric was
talking about and some more
intermediate tutorials that
experienced developers will be
quite comfortable jumping into
straight away.
And then for people who really
just want to start coding and
get used to the autocomplete and
sort of see what kinds of
methods they can drill down to
within each of our sort of
primary classes, that Start
Scripting button right at the
top of the page just pops open
the script editor and--
ERIC KOLEDA: Away you go.
DAN LAZIN: --away you go.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's great.
Some people, even the tutorial,
they're like, ah,
get out of my way.
They just want to start typing
code as fast as possible.
We give people that option
right there.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
And I think one of the other
great things, if you take a
look at the sidebar off to the
left, the sort of main
navigation, we've reorganized
this.
It's got all the same content
as before, well, with an
exception that we'll talk about
in a moment, but it
organizes them in a way that I
think sort of represents the
progression that people take
through learning Apps Script.
We start out with some
quickstart guides, get into
some of those intermediate
tutorials.
And then once you feel like
you've sort of found your
feet, if you start reading this
Guide section, you'll
find deeper information on each
of the major services,
best practices, that
kind of thing.
And then once you're really
flying and you just want the
reference day-to-day, that
Reference section breaks out
our major services into three
categories, allows you to look
up all of the just straight
API documentation, and get
straight to coding.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
That's something new here is
that before we kind of had all
of our services for the
most part lumped
into one big category.
The list was long.
It was hard to know
what did what.
Now this first section of Google
Apps Services, these
are kind of like your core
powerhouse services.
These are the things that allow
you to deeply integrate
with Google Apps, pull data
out, put data in.
Those are really kind of like
why you come to Google Apps
Script a lot of times.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
ERIC KOLEDA: And then these
other guys, here Advanced
Services, these are some
services that have a kind of a
different way that we integrate
with, a little bit
more for advanced users.
And then Script Services, these
are all the tools you
need to build scripts, not the
end goal, but the tools.
So I really like that new
structure as well.
And while we're talking about
reference documentation, we
also as part of this launch did
a complete overhaul of the
generated reference
documentation that we have.
DAN LAZIN: This is the least
flashy change here, but
probably the single most
important thing.
I mean, you'll look at this
front page from time to time,
but you'll be looking at
this stuff constantly.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
That's true.
You know, I spend most of my
time, even as an experienced
Apps Script user, constantly
referring back to these docs.
What is parameters?
What do they mean?
What do they do?
And so we've done
some changes.
One is that the actual
documentation that we're
presenting to you
is different.
We've gone through, added a lot
of new samples, clarified
some language, put in
some limitations.
So it's really a bit more
robust and complete.
And the second thing is we did
a little organization change
to the left nav here
as well, deeper in.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
Now you'll see what we call sort
of the entry point, like
the class that you use to
access the rest of the
service, is always the very
first thing in the category.
There are a few services that
have multiple entry points,
but anyway, they're always
sort of right to the top.
So you know that when you're
going to use Maps, you're
going to start with this
Maps link at the top.
Then below that, you get the
subclasses of Maps that allow
you to access the different
Maps objects and all the
methods that belong to
them are kind of
contained within them.
And then the sort of lesser
children, the cousins maybe,
are classed as interfaces
or enums
below the Classes section.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So it's kind of organized top to
bottom in kind of like what
things are you most likely
to refer to, right?
You're probably going to really
want to refer to the
Maps top level a lot, then maybe
the classes to get some
information.
And then enums and interfaces
less often you're going to
want to go down there
and poke around.
So it's really a good way to
kind of once again take what
is often a very large bit of
documentation that we have and
make it a bit easier
to digest.
DAN LAZIN: Apologies to those
people who for the first few
days are going to be a little
bit concerned or confused
about where to find things
they used to find.
We know that changes are
always disruptive.
But we think in the long term
this will provide a better
experience for you, certainly
a better experience for new
users, and really help grow the
Google Apps Script community.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's great.
I'm really excited about
these changes.
And I hope everybody else is
enjoying them as much.
So let's talk about some other
things that have happened
since the last "Apps
Unscripted." So a little bit
of other news is you might have
seen a blog post that
went out on the Google
Developers blog in general,
but also on our own blog about
how we're retiring a few Apps
Script components.
So there's going to be a few
small pieces of the UI
service, UI app, as it's
sometimes known, a few little
pieces that either never worked
correctly or that just
have better replacements.
Those are being kind
of deprecated and
then eventually sunset.
And I guess the bigger news
of it is the GUI builder.
If you haven't used it before,
it was kind of the drag and
drop way to build
user interfaces.
It wasn't quite complete.
It didn't have all
the widgets.
And we just thought that it
wasn't really servicing as
important a need, and we just
have better ways to build UIs
now, especially with the
launch of HTML service.
So go to our blog.
You can check out this blog
post for more information.
And there's a Sunsets page in
our documentation that talks
about when these will go away.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
Basically, you've got six months
from a few weeks ago,
so mid-September is when these
guys are getting turned off.
Depending on which component
we're talking about, they'll
either cease to function
entirely in September or still
remain accessible to existing
scripts but not be accessible
to new scripts.
So make sure you take a look at
that and see if there's any
transition you have to do
for your existing guys.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's great.
And just to be clear, because
we have had a little bit of
confusion, UI app, the UI
service as a whole, is not
going anywhere.
DAN LAZIN: That's right.
ERIC KOLEDA: A few small parts
that were kind of sitting in
the corner unused, those
are being cleaned away.
But the whole of it
is staying there.
Feel free to continue
to use UI app.
We sometimes recommend people
to look to HTML service if
you've never really
given it a shot.
We think it has some
nice benefits.
But UI app will remain,
so rest assured.
Another bit of news, we had
another blog post about--
"Hack to School" was
the name of it.
So this was great.
One of our colleagues, Arun,
who you've probably seen on
these programs that we've done
many times, he helped
participate in an event
here in the New
York City area that--
DAN LAZIN: I don't know if
we call New Jersey the
New York City area.
ERIC KOLEDA: The metro area.
It invited both coders and
teachers to come together to
create solutions
for education.
So teachers and administrators
have a lot of problems that
they deal with.
It's a very complex working
environment.
And they, a lot of times,
utilize Google Apps to kind of
handle this, spreadsheets
and pass data around.
And it's really quite useful.
But with Google Apps Script,
they can get a little bit
further and make these systems
that they build
that much more powerful.
And so this was a really great
event where they got people
together, made it a competition,
and I think came
up with some good results.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
It's really amazing how widely
the education community has
embraced Apps Script.
It's I think an accident
on our part.
It's not like Apps Script
is really tailored
for that use case.
I think we often think of our
main users being like
businesses, enterprise,
kind of workflow guys.
But in some ways education users
have that constraint
even magnified, because you
get really very different
classes of users between the
sort of administrator,
teacher, and the students
you're delegating to.
And it's really interesting.
And I mean, there's also the
fact that we're free.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
Being free always helps.
DAN LAZIN: Always helps
in education, yeah.
ERIC KOLEDA: So check
out that blog post.
There's some really cool stuff
that they came up with.
And if you're interested in
hacking for education, I'm
sure they could use
more volunteers.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
ERIC KOLEDA: So reach
out there.
Well, now we've got through
some of the news.
Let's jump into release notes,
which is our last
little bit of news.
As you know, we put out release
notes for every little
Apps Script release.
These releases kind of roll
out in the background.
There's no big version
numbers.
You don't actually see
them happening.
DAN LAZIN: We'd be a very,
very high version
number if we did.
ERIC KOLEDA: We would.
But when the releases do come
out, we create documentation
around what changed.
And I think since our last
"Google Apps Unscripted,"
there hasn't been a terrible
amount of change.
As you can see, on the 18th we
did make a small change to the
UI where the action Publish to
Gallery is now called Submit
to Gallery.
So we have a script gallery that
allows people to take a
spreadsheet script and stick
it in a place where other
people can download it
and use it, kind
of a sharing mechanism.
We just wanted to make sure
people didn't confuse that
with publish as a web app,
since that's kind of a
completely different flow.
So that was one small
change we made.
And then more recently,
we did a couple bug
fixes you can see here.
One of the ones of interest is
range.mergeAcross and merge
and mergeVertically.
There's different ways to merge
cells in a spreadsheet.
And we had these three methods
and they didn't quite work
quite right.
I think they kind of overlapped
in behavior.
It's all sorted out now,
though, right?
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
I've tested it.
It's just like you'd expect.
It's one of those things.
You get a release note, it's
like this now works correctly.
What more is there to say?
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, that's
what it's meant for.
So yeah, those are some
of the release notes.
That's about it as
far as news goes.
So we're really interested in
seeing if anybody in the
Hangout has any questions.
Let's jump in.
Do we have any Hangout
participants with
questions for us?
DAN LAZIN: Hey, look.
Our friends.
Do we have any--
volume?
HARRY: I've got one question.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
Hi.
HARRY: Hello.
My name is Harry [INAUDIBLE]
from the Netherlands.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
Hi, Harry.
HARRY: Hi.
A while ago I wanted to
share a spreadsheet
script via the gallery.
But I noted it was only possible
with a personal
account, and not just a
Google Apps account.
Is that still the case,
or has it changed?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yes.
I believe that still
is the case.
I think it's a limitation
that they didn't---
I don't know if it's across
the board or if it's a
domain-specific setting.
But I guess there was some
concern that you may write a
script that is internal
information and that you
accidentally share it to the
public without realizing it,
and how that could be
somewhat damaging.
So I think it's kind of a safety
mechanism that you
cannot submit to the
gallery from one
of your domain accounts.
DAN LAZIN: You've discovered
the workaround, thankfully,
all on your own.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So we do have some people who
when they want to share a
script will do it from a
separate personal account.
And that's probably the best
thing you can do right now.
DAN LAZIN: Thanks for
the question, Harry.
Any other questions live
via the Hangout?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
I am trying to share.
I have an issue that I want to
separate my user interface
from the back end, or the
service I think you'd
probably call it.
And I'm looking at using content
service and JSONP.
I've got to the point where
you get a terrible warning
saying if you do this you're
going to expose yourself to
spoofing attacks and
things like that.
I understand that.
I wonder, there are obviously
ways to get
better protection here.
And I wondered whether
you have a general
guide to doing that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Gotcha.
Yeah.
I think I saw your question
pop up in
the Moderator before.
Yeah.
As he was mentioning, we have
a warning in our content
service documentation about
how when you use a JSONP
service, or set up content
service to act as a JSONP
service, there's a little
bit of danger in
that you are taking--
if you publish a script to run
as you, and now you're making
it accessible via just a
JavaScript include, you're
potentially allowing other
people to access your data,
because that script, there's
no authentication mechanism
built into the content service
and being able to ask people
to authenticate.
So because of that, if you open
it up publicly so anybody
can use it, then someone else
could look at your web page
code, take that same bit of
script, and then all of a
sudden access your data
on their own web page.
So there is a little
bit danger there.
There is no, right now, way to
do it in an authenticated way.
We don't have quite the
mechanism set up for that.
So using the content service
which JSONP, it's possible.
But I would say--
DAN LAZIN: You want to be
careful essentially what type
of data you expose to it.
Certain types of things you're
going to be OK with.
Others not so much.
It's really the sort of thing
where the developer wants to
make a sanity check against
what kinds of
data they're exposing.
ERIC KOLEDA: Right.
Does that help?
Are there other questions
around that?
MALE SPEAKER: Not really.
You do provide the
authentication if you run as--
if you're looking at it
running within the
domain, if you like.
What I was looking for was
something that would actually
support a secondary
authentication, like your
standard mechanism
with two-phase--
you know, getting an SMS
message, for instance, when
you log on.
If you did that at the
application level and stored
that as a cookie, that
would provide that
anti-spoofing mechanism.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I mean, there are probably some
things that we could do
on the product side to make this
kind of more robust and
better meet your needs.
I don't think that's
anywhere--
you're not going to see
that in the near term.
If there's something that you
can code up that you think
will help with your
authentication and security
issues, that's fine.
But as far as like a product
feature, I don't think you're
going to see that in
the near term.
So I would say feel
free to use JSONP
for certain use cases.
But I think maybe for others,
a different integration
mechanism might be a better
way to go about.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
What would that be?
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, it
kind of depends.
You mentioned wanting
to separate your UI
from your back end.
I mean, we're working on
improving our HTML service
documentation.
We have different people on our
team working on creating
some new samples.
And if you've used the HTML
service, it actually has a
really nice library built into
it, so that when you're in the
front end of your application,
the HTML, JavaScript, that's
running client side, you can
call google.script.run and it
does an RPC call back to
the back end, does some
processing, gets the result.
And then you can display
it via jQuery
or some other library.
So I find the separation there
is actually really nice, where
the HTML service page that you
serve to the user is really
kind of just mostly focused on
the UI and handling the data.
And then your back end GS file
Apps Script code is focused
purely on doing some
processing.
DAN LAZIN: And you can sort
of strictly control what
functions are accessible to
google.script.run and that
code will only run while you're
on script.google.com.
It's a really nice sandboxing
that takes care of
most of it for you.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So I would say you can
use JSONP as a tool.
But as more of a solution, I
think HTML service is probably
there as a better solution.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
ERIC KOLEDA: Great.
Other questions live before we
jump into the Moderator?
DAN LAZIN: Sounds like a no.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
That's a no.
Let's keep going on the
Moderator, then.
So we have some questions
here on the Moderator.
I'll take a look.
So one of the first ones here
is short term rate limits on
JDBC calls.
And is there a difference if
you're using our regular JDBC
connector versus the
CloudSQL connector.
And can we increase them?
So if you go to the URL
script.google.com/dashboard,
this is where we will display,
first of all, whether we have
any sort of outages that we know
about, but also a lot of
our quotas.
So the only restriction I could
find on JDBC are these
two here, which is how many
connections you can make on a
per-day basis.
Now there also are--
see, there's like some
shorter term limits.
I think it's like one connection
per second.
So if you open a connection,
you can do a lot of work
within that connection and I
don't think you're going to
run into any problems there.
But it does seem like you want
to not open lots and lots of
connections.
So open a connection, get one
field, close it, open another
connection, get one field,
close it, right?
If you keep it open, I think
you probably won't run into
the one-second limit.
And I'd also be surprised if
you ran into 10,000 a day.
So take a look at
those limits.
If for whatever reason you have
a use case that's really
important and one of these
numbers is holding you up,
file something in our
Issue Tracker.
And we can take a look and
see if we can change it.
But for the most part, I think
those are probably in line.
And if you just don't
open too many
connections, you'll be OK.
So the next one we have here,
that's the JSONP that we
already talked about.
Let's talk about the HTML
service, then, from Anatoly.
I don't know if I
said that right.
So that's a lot of questions
packed into one here.
We're asking about keyboard
events, disabling the
right-click, opening up new
windows, setting the fixed
element position.
There's probably a lot of
different answers, because
there's a lot of different
questions.
One of the things about HTML
service, I guess just to set
the board, is that you are using
kind of like for the
most part standard HTML,
JavaScript, and CSS.
The only limitation is that we
kind of put a little layer in
between what you write and what
the user gets for safety.
So you'll notice that your web
apps served off of HTML
service serve off of
script.google.com.
Google.com, that little part of
the URL has a lot of power.
And so we need to be extra
careful that we don't let
things through that
can be damaging.
So we use a sanitization engine
called Caja, that we've
talked about before on this
program, that will go in and
make sure that what you're doing
isn't dangerous, that
you're not accessing anything
you shouldn't access, you're
not breaking out of places you
shouldn't break out of.
So that engine today does create
some weird limitations.
I know, Dan, you've looked a
lot into the Caja world.
And there's definitely
some things that
today you can't do.
I know there's stuff
about setting code
directly in your HTML.
I think they usually
want it not
attached to the HTML element.
So there are some limitations.
And we're working better right
now-- we actually have a
project underway that should
make this a lot easier.
And hopefully I'll be able
to show you that soon.
But for the meantime, for the
most part the way you would do
something in Apps Script HTML
service is the way you would
do it in any HTML.
DAN LAZIN: Really the rule of
thumb right now is try to do
it in the normal way.
If it doesn't work in the
normal way, occasionally
there's a workaround.
For the most part, if it doesn't
work that's because
Caja's getting in the way.
If you sort of pop open your
browser's inspection panel and
see if you've got any console
log warnings or see if you can
see how Caja has rewritten your
page, you might be able
to find the source of the bug
and work around that.
But a lot of the times, really
the advice is try to do it in
the normal way.
If it doesn't work, it might not
work for now until we get
these improvements to the way
that Caja and HTML service
integrate that Eric's
talking about.
And more news on that for
you hopefully soon.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
And the thing is, why you run
into these problems with Caja
is that Caja is very strict.
There's the JavaScript
specification, the ECMA
specification, and it
goes by the book.
And it turns out that a lot of
browsers are really loose.
They'll allow pretty much
anything through as long as
it's close.
And so because of that, some
code that may have worked in a
browser and that someone posted
on Stack Overflow or
some other forum that says,
here's a solution, that may
not work by the strict rules
of the specification.
And so a lot of times you'll be
running into that problem,
where we're just being more
strict on code than a browser
normally would be.
HARRY: Can I ask a question
related to that?
ERIC KOLEDA: Sure.
HARRY: Until now, I've mainly
used the UI app, but the HTML
service looks quite promising.
But I understood it's
using HTML4.
Can we also use it with HTML5
and Bootstrap, for example?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yes.
Bootstrap is a popular
request.
DAN LAZIN: It can use certain
elements of HTML5.
I believe if you actually take
a look at the page that's
served, it is actually
technically an HTML5 doc type.
We sort of describe it as
HTML4-like today, because
although serving an HTML5 page
removes a lot of the APIs that
are available exclusively in
HTML5, your web workers and
local storage, that kind of
thing, but for the most part
your HTML5 elements should be
available and accessible and
they should work as you would
expect them to work in HTML5.
So for example, I think you can
use the canvas element,
which is an HTML5 thing.
It's been around in HTML
service for a while.
To be honest, one of the
problems with using HTML
service these days is the
documentation is a little bit
disorganized.
We have a new version of that.
It's almost ready to go.
And if you've got a project
where you think HTML service
would be really good right now,
we all learned it from
the existing documentation
but it was a bit of pain.
You can do that.
But if you can wait a few weeks,
if it's just a sort of
experimental project where
you're waiting, then maybe we
can get you some new, cleaner
documentation soon.
HARRY: I'm curious to give
it a try before that.
DAN LAZIN: Yeah.
It's all there.
All the information is there.
It's just you'll be jumping
around a bit, that's all.
HARRY: Yeah.
Good.
ERIC KOLEDA: And for Bootstrap
in particular, I know people
have been asking for it.
And we're going to make a
stronger effort in the future
to kind of take these high
profile, critical libraries
and setups and make sure that
they work, because it seems
like a lot of people, they want
Bootstrap from the beginning.
They don't want to have
to fiddle around.
DAN LAZIN: JQuery, for example,
is very popular with
HTML service.
It's extensively tested.
We ensure that both jQuery
and jQuery UI work
right out of the box.
If you take a look, there's
actually some canonical links
for jQuery and jQuery UI that
are listed in our HTML service
documentation that'll speed
up your app a bit.
ERIC KOLEDA: Great.
HARRY: Thank you.
ERIC KOLEDA: No problem.
Any other live questions while
we're here in the Hangout?
DAN LAZIN: Back to
the Moderator.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
Off we go.
Feel free to chime in later.
So the next one here we have is,
"Is it possible to use the
and-and and or-or--" or just
ampersand-ampersand and
pipe-pipe "operators
as 'and' and 'or'
in Google Apps Script?
I've tried to do it and I can't
make it work nor find
the documentation."
Well, you can.
So Google Apps Script at its
core is just JavaScript.
DAN LAZIN: And JavaScript at its
core is just ECMAScript.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
Exactly.
DAN LAZIN: It goes
all the way down.
ERIC KOLEDA: All the way down.
And so yes, because JavaScript
supports these, they work in
Apps Script.
Unfortunately, I don't know
why you were having
problems with it.
But do some more testing.
Try it out.
Sometimes when I'm testing
things I'll actually try to
run the code in my
browser first.
So like Google Chrome, the
browser, has a great little
console where you can
type in JavaScript
code and see it run.
It's a really fast way to kind
of like see whether or not a
piece of code runs.
And so try some stuff
out there.
But yeah, in general anything
that's part of JavaScript or
ECMAScript should
work just fine.
Great.
Last one.
I've got a couple more here.
"Are there any plans to allow
set page-level permissions for
Sites?" Page-level
permissions--
ah.
Yes.
I think there is a feature
request for this
in our Issue Tracker.
The feature is that Google
Sites you can either set
permissions on the whole site
or you can enable per-page
permissions.
And currently in Apps Script we
don't expose those per-page
permission settings.
But I understand that they are
popular, so I think there's an
open issue for that.
DAN LAZIN: Request we can
pass on to the team.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, exactly.
And so if you lodge your
interest there, that will help
us better prioritize it.
DAN LAZIN: One thing that we say
almost every time in "Apps
Unscripted" here is when you've
got a feature request,
please file it in our
Issue Tracker.
And if you see an existing
feature request that you think
would be really useful for you,
make sure to add a little
star next to it.
That's really what we use
as our priority list for
community-requested feature
development.
If you look back in the release
notes a couple weeks,
there was one week we had a
spate of new features that we
added that were pretty much
all community requests.
Someone on the team finished up
a little project they were
working on and got really
excited to address some of
those pending things.
So we have a lot of users.
We can't address everybody's
requests.
We just don't have enough
engineering time and the
product would grow to be sort
of unwieldally large.
That's not a word.
But we do take a look at
everything that comes in and
prioritize them based on the
community votes they get.
So get out there and tell
us what you want.
ERIC KOLEDA: Sounds great.
Yeah.
It's good for you.
It's good for us.
Everybody wins.
DAN LAZIN: One of the funny
things about Apps Script, I
always say, is that we're always
really surprised at the
things that people are doing
with it, for example, the
popularity of Apps Script
in education.
And the things that we find
people are doing from looking
at Stack Overflow or our Issue
Tracker sometimes diverge from
what we thought people would
use features for.
And the only way we can
learn about those is
for you to tell us.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
That's a good point.
All right.
So we're just about
out of time.
Let's address one more question
here that has some
votes, which is someone saying,
"I'm terribly--" it
just popped up.
And I lost it.
"I'm terribly disappointed
by the decision to
discontinue UI Builder.
Do you have any plans to replace
it with a drag and
drop UI builder for
HTML service?
There are some good ones out
there, but something that
integrates with Google
Apps Script
would be good." Yeah.
I mean, I've actually heard
some other people already
request this, kind of.
And I think we're going to start
testing out whether some
of those ones will work
with HTML service.
I think in general, it might
lead to a solution where we'll
recommend or ask you to use
another drag and drop HTML
service and then bring that
into Google Apps Script.
It may not be just built into
the UI as it was before.
But we're trying to make more
and more HTML service behave
like normal HTML.
So if you can find a tool that
works in normal HTML, we want
to support that.
And I think that could be
another great way to kind of
get some of the same features
of GUI Builder but now using
HTML service, if we can find a
popular one, ensure that it
works, and make sure that our
HTML service just behaves like
normal HTML.
DAN LAZIN: That would
be great.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
Well, that's about it.
That's all the time we have
for this episode of "Apps
Unscripted." Thanks everyone
who joined us
live and asked questions.
Thanks for watching us
live on YouTube.
And this recording will be
available shortly for anyone
who missed it.
Dan, thanks for joining us.
DAN LAZIN: Thank you
for having me.
Thanks, everybody.
ERIC KOLEDA: And we'll
see you next time.
Good bye.
DAN LAZIN: Good talking
to you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]